oh my god I'm about to meet the yodeling
kid hello everyone even here and I'm at
the 2018 Radio Disney Music Awards
asking select to build their dream
Disney squad let's go who would you pick
as your Disney Squad if you have to pick
like three or four Disney characters
from your favorite movies and a place
you would take them probably Rapunzel
from tangled
I'd be at first Simba young Simba
definitely where would you take them
you're going on vacation where High
School Musical squad high school and be
like yo fill my School Musical 4 I'm
signing that petition
maybe Bell from beating I mean I don't
know that's my favorite movie I still
got the biggest crush on her so you
would take her on a date more like I
would take her more than just a day I
would literally like I'd take her to the
beach or something I don't know I didn't
know where that was going for a second I
wanna have a good summer this summer so
I would choose Shia LaBeouf and holes I
would choose Jett Jackson I love him I
love him I miss him I love him I would
choose Joe Jackson and I would choose
the guy from the Jersey - and I want
Nick Spano cuz you love me and I love
you okay maybe just now is that that
would be it but that to me sounds more
like a date with mouths and just hanging
out with a squad and I'd the Emperor
from Emperor's New Groove I would have
the the dude that like is his friendly a
big guy I'll be here yeah yeah yeah I
gotta go with Hercules
Hades Donald Duck and my girlfriend Maya
amazing combination alright and we're we
should take all of them where would I
take them yeah probably Disney will
Disneyland a big fan of course a me too
yeah sure can I join love that wear this
shirt for you any day so I'm here with
Mason Ramsey I just met him I'm super
excited we're trying to find out who
would you pick as your Disney squad if
you have to pick like two or three
Disney characters that you really like
is there any Disney if you have a squad
where would you take your squad go home
and chill hello Captain Jack II guess
Jack Sparrow's duty
Kim Possible luck and possible Raven
Symone who I work with but she'd be
amazing she's already a squad I feel
like we already form our own squad
within our caste oh yeah but that's an
idea like Disney squad
[Music]